besonders man nicht sowieso verwirrt und
total lassen
wer nicht auf das häufig sie jetzt noch
genau denn man ist einfach so passiert
ja ich weiss einfach glücklich sein der
flachen land ist tief ich
[Musik]
berlin
liebe fragt nicht nach dem pass liebe
kann grenzenlos sein
liebe nimmt uns an der hand kulturen
sind wir hin und weg das sind schweizer
liebesgeschichten aus aller welt
[Musik]
ich bin's nebraska dorner hetzte thomas
dummermuth weckte levy verschlagen
[Gelächter]
nicht nur stars league und
kaffeemaschine an amerikanische
filterkaffee verzichte thomas mitwählen
töne aus nebraska und thomas im emmental
hat sich als teenager auf internet
kennengelernt
wir waren bei den wien offenbar mit dem
namen mozart
es war eine intensive begegnung ganz
viele leute aus unterschiedlichen
ländern waren dort die stimme gesprochen
für mehr erfolg den sprung der moment
und und
weil du liefern ehre was das war ich
kann es immer noch kaum glauben dass wir
heute hier sind
das ist unglaublich besser als alle
träume und märchen
bis der jenny von iris meyer li
wirklichkeit wurden ist aber ziemlich
viel zeit braucht und einiges
abhängigkeit
das ist ich stelle mich absolut schweiz
das ist für den schweizer
das war meine erste reise in die schweiz
ich wollte unbedingt dass er mich auch
besucht um zu wissen dass es ihm ernst
ist und er hatte es mir versprochen die
fonds hätte thomas aber vorher über das
unter wenig bilden uns da raus und dann
spricht das meer und sonst überhaupt
etwas klarheit mir da nicht reiche
erfahrung mit
das ist eine sprache und
geschäftsbeziehungen funktioniert und
wir dass mir da das bis dahin im spiel
des staates einfordern
also das ist gottes wille dass du dort
ist ja gottes für biophysik
[Musik]
mit fünf stimmen und den kosmos kaffee
trinken und dann wird ja eh nur irgend
sondern was auch immer ich halte derzeit
extrem schwierig gefunden irgendwie mich
aufregen der besitzer und haben einfach
offen hat schon mal vorweg es erst mal
nur s-bahnen später ist alles anders
der milan und ein freund von ihm helfen
das arab im zyklen nach der trennung von
ihrem ehemann ist sarah in einem
provisorium und jetzt wie sich das neue
ist die haie richter mit der idee dass
viele milan bald könnte ziehen und her
zwischen serbien und der schweiz werden
einfach langsam höher sein
aber zuerst geht's noch an feste
problems lösen
sarah hat anka um heikle fracht in
erinnerung euro vorjahr gestorben ist es
nicht packen und dann ist schluss
gemerkt dass der modus für mich und dann
einfach irgendwo ein wenig 8
dies ist also bietet aber dass alles gut
ist
der froschkönig
viel wertvoller als der froschkönig die
stars von ihrer mutter auf dem weg ins
neue leben begleitet
[Musik]
schweizer alpen sind neuland für die
milan erlebte belgrad für zara sind
strenge taxi aber jetzt hat sie bald
auch ihre scheidung hinter sich ist so
heißt es abwarten und dann ist das
erledigt ist wirklich nur noch
schriftlich ereignisse
[Musik]
dober auf dem titlis endlichen moment
zum thema gemüse
[Musik]
ja man muss sich natürlich wieder daran
gewöhnen dass man das land teil das muss
durch die kompromisse aber das ist okay
langweilig wird dass sarah und dem elan
der nächste große schritt steht schon
wir planen so bald als möglich nach
belgrad zu gehen und zu heiraten
hochzieht
in der heimat von milan nur mit ein paar
freunden so jedenfalls unsere absicht
aber wer weiß
foto bliebe mir dass ich habe es mit
allem zusammen beistand verantworten
[Musik]
sie stehen ja ja
winkend hauptstadt von gebrauchs kratz
mit die die vereinigten staaten ein ort
wo man da einfach so viel geordert die
richtige frau wohnte sie zickig nebraska
die high vom emmental pfarrer thomas
dummermuth was ist heimat für seine frau
jenny 14 12 der micro und dass das mit
vor zwei nationen im bann dass es nicht
so war er dann ist es vorbei
normalerweise ist mit ihm eine familie
sprachbildung englisch aber um thomas
wieczorek spürt mit trotzdem er hat
musik mitgebracht wir singen zb die
schweizer gute nacht oder tischgebete er
brauchte auch bücher aus der schweiz mit
grundsatz noch sieht man sich einig was
kinder zwar gut aber es geschah
unterschied
thomas und ich erzählen die kinder
unterschiedlich aber ich weiß nicht ob
das damit zu tun hat dass er schweizer
ist oder mit seiner eigenen
der dorfpfarrer vorne re presbyterianer
meint presbyterianer kürze der
reformierter viele
800 mitglieder für linken ist darf er
mittelgroße gemeinschaft hört geht es
voran brett ich schriebe gottesdienst
vorbereiten
und ja wie in einem dorf im soll
die muss natürlich vorbereitet sie ist
das ist das separate für das ja
[Musik]
das lego aber das ist super dass das
nicht das animieren sagt sorgte das
gesamte katholische kirche lauter wo sie
sich befinden und aber also ist die
amerikanische singer ist dass jeder vor
der jugendkammer hat natürlich keine
amerikaner wesentlicher becher trinken
mit der mann mit dem sohn vor gott würde
jeden tag da muss ja dass jäger bacher
und so post das inlands distanz
die
meine mutter ist eine tradition auf sie
wollte dass ich ein mann die unsere
kultur kennen heiratete sie war ein
bisschen enttäuscht enttäuscht dass ich
möchte ein ich möchte mir täte
verheiratet
aber sie war endlich glücklich war peter
ist ein drittel ein
[Musik]
the scenes malaysia im heimatland von
jeannette
[Musik]
sie sind zivil show sieht vier york über
das quartal und die zwei nachholen was
der schweiz nicht möglich sich als
riesiges hochzeitsfest mit über 400
gästen mit gazprom kleider polen mit
tipi ist susan mama von jeannette wie
schon monatelang mit der
hochzeitsvorbereitungen beschäftigt
[Gelächter]
sie ist so hübsch
für jeanette wird im traum war
eigentlich
ich denke in der schweiz kann ich das
nicht haben
falls nicht möglich für sie wollten aber
das war astronomische für so etwas
[Musik]
so schön sauer sommer nach light will
client sie
[Musik]
als ich
peters geburts zeigt und die von
jeanette um zu berechnen wann die
hochzeit stattfinden muss damit das paar
unter einem glücklichen stern steht
damit sie für immer glücklich sind all
diese zahlen müssen harmonieren
geomantie seid mir der rückversicherung
für das glücklos leibe und malaysia gibt
es neben x6 schwanger ist dann durfte
ich in meiner hochzeit zu kommen war es
gibt zwei positiven energie die wir
zusammen stoßen wird und dass es nicht
geht
aber da probt orthovita am hochzeitsfest
muss sich jeanette vier mal umziehen
reuters
[Musik]
es ist
kapierte jetzt die frau tätigen so
hierüber verschwiegen werden
zunächst
[Musik]
ich glaube es ist ein vorteil dass man
interkulturelle harry patch
interkulturell und unter das dass das
wie immer elefant ist immer im ruhm
das hilft sachen die zeit verstärkt mal
was was nochmals für mega schnitt man
mal versehen und dadurch sehr handlich
und der lust verstanden ist und der
blues nachfrage und meint wiederholt
[Musik]
brian hospitals linken nebraska das
privatspital 640 bett 2012 schafe genf
ich bin doktor nikoleit ich bin ihre
zuständige ärztin freut mich sie zu
sehen
ich übernehme heute gut da gibt es noch
ein bisschen was zu tun
mein vater hat mich ermutigt einen beruf
zu ergreifen
etwas bedeutet dazu kommt dass meine
jüngste schwester im alter von fünf
monaten unerwartet verstarb
[Musik]
dieses ereignis hat auch dazu
beigetragen dass ich ärztin werden
wollte
jenny vortritt ihrem beruf verlangt sind
nicht nur medizinische psychologische
fähigkeiten
man muss mit verlust umgehen können
thomas und ich haben beide die fähigkeit
leuten zu helfen die sich in schwierigen
umständen befinden
ich glaube diese bord war für mich vor
bestimmt
[Musik]
david geht rooney den usa für jennifer
100 prozent genauso wieder thomas einer
beide volle pension zwei hindurchzieht
buchs viel organisation energie und
vollem engagement von beiden antrete
[Musik]
das ist ja hinter selbstverständlich
dass eine partnerschaft ist es diese
betragen hat juni waschen und ich hoffe
das mache ich sehr gern und und und und
ruhm anrufen soll und 6
[Musik]
ich nie langweilig sie ich weiß es nicht
50 jahre sind oder lange man denkt gar
nicht daran an diana schafer sind war
schwierig ist sie aber man lädt durch
die schwierige zeit
ich habe wahnsinnig viel geld
[Musik]
1,4 milliarden angeles indien nach china
bono
am stadtrand von mumbai and russia unter
bernard im hasli ihres daseins gebaut
nachdem dpa zehn jahre das wirtschafts
wort und als in die content aufgehellt
schrieben wird er immer noch regelmäßig
über in die hauptsächlich für das
online-journal wenn man sich bewusst
wird die unsichere infrastruktur wir
hier immer nur hey ich bin erfahren
ein strom hat jeder morgen ist das quasi
wie mit dem olympus stoffs gebaut
hoffentlich der strom relativ stabil und
sind die telefonverbindung also die
weitere bände ich die städte die vielen
artikel und bücher hat sich der beirat
mit seiner zweite heimatlosen angesetzt
kritisch aber mit viel sympathie also
als langweiler entdeckt nicht als
journalist sondern als jemand war ein
ähnlicher fall kater hat war also
irgendwo es ist interesse hat erstens
dass es dem land gutgeht würde also
internationale verbindungen
und zweitens dass man versucht das land
besser versteht das ist so ja
wir sind die frau engagiert sich alte
bernard für bessere bildung im land mit
stiftungen unterstützen sie verschiedene
schulprojekte illusion quasi ein inder
zwar immerhin ein schweizer oder europa
hier eher in indien als welle bliebe und
das glaube ich aber bereit
bis sie offenbar nicht mit allzu stark
identifizieren mit halo ist also keine
schule heute schon zurück dann lernen
wir heute noch ein bisschen englisch alt
hast du deine prüfung
im haus liegen die stammtische pause
familie so heißt ihr ihn doch die
ursprünglich aus dem heutigen iran auf
ihn die rosing rasch nach gibt ihn dir
und auf der ganzen welt workshops zum
thema ehe und partnerschaft sie will die
indische mythologie nicht einfach deinen
über lahr wo sie brauchen zum schwächere
unter druck und dir wo unterdrückt sind
dass sich der neue burg was ist denn
jetzt zeigen dass eigentlich wenn man
mit hofstaat für sich selber da passiert
mit der blieb man unterdrückt level am
drahtseil profillos der indische
mythologie gelernt die ihren kurs
probiert sie iris wüster zusammen mit
ihrer erfahrung aus 50 yards nutzer
jetzt weiß ich was mich dann übernimmt
das alles verstanden
man ist möglich nummern kontrollen das
verstanden jetzt also daran wie immer
quasi der lehrer verdienen mit sind das
nicht die lehren wurden von anderen
akzeptiert dass sich privatpersonen ist
eine irre lerne ich fühle mich so
beglückt dass ich mich hätte
unterstützen wenn ich nämlich spezielle
studieren oder so hätten sogar
unterstützt und ich bin so privilegiert
auf meter läufer nominiert
ich finde sich zieht sich bis inkl
[Musik]
ich liebe die art wie thomas nachdenkt
man kann ihm dabei zusehen
ich lerne von ihm unkonventionell zu
denken
ich liebe das
[Musik]
das manifest agadir der neue blick
professur amerikanisches fest
es ist halloween und da im schulzentrum
wird klartext üblich dass robert was ja
auch in sevilla die gute mütter und
väter die machen ganz kreativ am anfang
ist das gefühl hier ihren und so wie
heutzutage ping ist irgendwie noch cool
es ist von einer stimme im jahr ist
plant ford amerikaner oder man kann
darauf lud er kenne also zum beispiel
klinker verkürzte und sagt ob es einmal
gemacht die den usa hübsch taxis oder
weniger moment wo das noch passiert und
dass das ging jetzt mal cool
ja und trinken wir bis liebesfragen und
das
[Musik]
hätte
mai
[Musik]
am schluss treffen sich dutzende heiße
schokolade
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nur deutsch mathe die lmbv am spricht
ich gar kein deutsch sehr wenig und es
sei immer 14 gesetzte aber das macht er
nicht so oft und das macht mir sehr gut
und nötig
[Musik]
dort malaysia ist was ich muss aufpassen
es gab noch zwei tage bis zum große
hochzeitsfest
unterdessen sind
ich habe mir das nie
das ist schweinebauch da nehme ich nur
den lokführern im stress dazu ja also
ich bin sehr froh dass jetzt das auge
sehen und erleben wie sagte schon sowie
und soja jetzt ist es für ältere einen
überraschungshit aus der paypal frau aus
malaysia geortet also wenn nicht frieren
ganz wenn der frische der pubertät am
anfang hätte nur für blondinen
[Gelächter]
der apfel fällt nicht weit vom stamm
denke ich habe mir nie frei halt damals
in jugoslawien
also ich hatte in jugoslawien hatte ob
es schweizer aber der kern ist das
wägeli wiederholt sich geschichte nur
einfach die stolze warten erklingt ein
dass momente bucht zum täterinnen
akzeptieren familie wird sehr hoch
gehalten
seit jahren in asien generell der
familiäre zusammenhalt ist sehr wichtig
zunächst dachte ich mich so ist er kein
chinese
aber dann merkte ich peter ist ein sehr
netter kerl dann akzeptierte ich ihn
schnell aus
zuerst fand ich großes glück dass mein
kleines mädchen seine liebe gefunden hat
dann kamen die üblichen zweifel ist
dieser junge gut genug für sie
ich war weder rasse hautfarbe nur den
jungen wie irgendein dann wussten wir
natürlich auch dass die ehe mit einem
schweizer bedeuten würde dass sie weit
weg von uns wurden wird
das ist der traurige teil
aber das gibt überwiegt
[Musik]
amerikaner gerek glück sie war es damit
alle das aus drei metern zu schmal
geschaut und lobt das ist dass frieden
und schnitte hier siege
sonntagmorgens linken nebraska
[Musik]
bald ströme blüht zum thomas thiele ich
bin noch früher dran der thomas bereiter
grad mit der mitarbeit dritte
gottesdienst sprung thomas ist ein guter
fahrer
er hat ein gutes herz man kommt leicht
mit ihm ins gespräch
er verbreitet gute botschaften das alles
braucht vor amerikaner forschung zu alt
für das sie große angst prediger lengwil
wahrscheinlich man sich länger aber sie
kommen nicht sagen dass ich jetzt auf
ihre moment kurz berichtet trägt ja der
kommen aber die kommt aber die große
frage kann man noch weiß und muss
absprachen und aus richtung tor aber der
richtig große mainz natürlich jetzt bin
ich in varese als informations und die
amerikanische und schweizer und so jetzt
der schweizer ist denn der unterschied
amerikanisch so der schweizer fällt das
beste
[Musik]
nie
sie können sich sitzen nun bitten wir
brennen mit seinen eltern und paten in
nach vorne
braucht die anderen kinder können hier
kommen ich taufe dich im namen des
vaters und des heiligen geistes armen
aber da gibt es noch mehr dass wir hier
feiern
wir freuen uns über dieses wunderbare
kehrt in unsere mitte natürlich wird es
überall zeigen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein
anders in der schweiz gibt es amerika
drei viele stühle sind vollständig auf
spenden angewiesen
darum ist es wichtig dass predigten von
thomas das erste mal sah ich ihn in der
schweiz predigen mit einem katholischen
priester zusammen
es machte mir mühe thomas pfarrer zu
sehen ich wurde eben katholisch erzogen
und katholische pfarrer steffen ja nicht
heiraten
außerdem verstand ich kein wort
jetzt habe ich mich daran gewöhnt wir
haben viel darüber geredet
unser ziel war wenn ich für ihn lässt
italienerin werte wird der nebraska
jetzt keine kritik lerne mutter jenny
für ihre familie kennen und sport selber
malaysia musik schwiegermutter ist sucht
und belgrad gsa für zara und der milan
ernst hin und weg